so wie sie ist das schon das sitzt auf
dem bett und wartet auf uns
ich höre mich an zwölfjähriger was ich
weiß nicht ich wollte nicht absetzen
ich war die ganze zeit hier verdammt
noch mal runter sterbehilfe ich glaube
deine leertaste vom laptop ist kaputt
nein aber irgendwie will dir nicht immer
heute nicht so gut drauf ich doch gar
nicht doch nein hört sich aber so an
hotspots
die zuschauer denken jetzt natürlich ja
ladet euch die map montag fliegt bis zu
dem punkt und dann sehen wir mal weiter
jetzt wollen wir uns noch vom hals
schaffen müssen die gleiche physische
voraussetzungen ja
es geht gar nicht klar
ich habe gerade auf einem handy gesehen
ich wollte viermal angerufen
irgendjemanden der mutter bestimmt nähe
von anonymous steht hey hallo wie gehts
wo ich betone du ich auch okay sehen uns
im himmel oder hölle keine ahnung
klappen wenn du runter fällt schlage ich
dich wieder hoch das wäre cool wenn
michael wenzel sprach sterben wir dann
auch so komisch umfallen die kripo oder
so du arschloch ich es fast geschafft
hätte sich eine charta letzte nicht
würde ich mich jetzt geschafft ich meine
ich hab das schon geschafft ist auf den
letzten job und ich verstehe ich das
jetzt nicht wieder schaffe ich das
einfach richtig mit abspringen ja ich
hab's geschafft letzter job
man kann nicht so laut ich werde es bis
hierhin hey ich hab mein gefährte
getroffen
wisst ihr müsst euch das so vorstellt
der war noch nass wenn die stadt ein
bisschen dreckig klappen bei meinem
zimmer wenn man reinkommt steht in der
hinter links hinten linken hinten links
hinten links städten tisch da ist mein
weg und mein zweiter bildschirm und
teilt die playstation so drauf und da
wenn ihr ins mal reinkommen steht rechts
direkt hängt entfernt oder ist der
versand und davor sitzt gerade martin
mit dem laptop einfach auf dem boden
das heißt martin hat gerade teilt gesagt
willst du sterben wie der deckel
genommen den auf martin geschmissen der
sitzt mit dem rücken zu mir damit ich
seine stimme nicht zu nordkorea das ist
alles audio mal hier
audio technisch abgemessen naja
jedenfalls china plant man kann ehrlich
auch das hörte sich ganz martin headset
weggeschmissen
nein
auf baumann martin bitte musste jemand
zu hause sein
oder willst du meine eltern warum uni
paderborn gucken warum er warum nicht
und dann denn da ist verkaufsoffener
sonntag auch noch ja wir gucken wenn du
die partie bot und was ist der wirkliche
grund warum mitarbeit bekommen jetzt
auch tag der offenen tür und ich wollte
halt scheiße ich wollte letzter sprung
ich wollte doch gucken
du willst dich wirklich noch martin
wir haben die ganze zeit gesagt wir
wurden die wissen doch dass in der nähe
von bielefeld bei uns erst einmal pause
das nach wieder fällt fest ach ja stimmt
und paderborn von wieder fällt mir ja
ein bisschen weiter weg
okay wenn man nie den ort gesagt wo wir
wohnen oder ich einmal aus versehen
unter nachbarn ort aber da hast du
gekonnt einen film darüber gesetzt ach
so habe ich meinen diese aufnahme
natürlich wurde also nur weil wir jetzt
gesagt haben martin fletcher und die
paderborn heißt nicht dass wir in
paderborn wohnen ich kann genauso gut
sagen ja ich weiß aus münchen
hey da wurde möglich weil das mädchen
das huhn es hier unten hallo ich muss
niesen
hallo niesen ich will dich töten nicht
dass du mit flammender stirbst nein ja
doch the world wtf ja ich habe ganz
schnell eingetippt jetzt über ein ganz
schnell strecke es geht viel schneller
wie sie ist das huhn das sitzt auf dem
bett und wartet auf uns los ist das ein
huhn welcher die flammen da rainha
übrigens werden uns wahrscheinlich schon
ganz viel in die kommentare geschrieben
haben so von wegen
haye kann auch einfach martin sicht oben
links einblenden oder so ja natürlich
können wir das aber den ct von martin
immer nur so ein bisschen von mir dann
auch den oberen teil natürlich gar nicht
deswegen gesagt wir wechseln einfach
zwischendurch aber verschieden das
fenster zum anderen sieht mir noch an
den namen ja daran auf
ich habe keine lust mehr auf diese
sprung seinen lappen
es ist ja nicht wirklich schwierig war
schon vier fünf mal vor diesem
entsprungen oder dreimal so also ich war
einmal nicht sein
doch er ist ins wasser gesprungen
geht zurück ich ertrinken nicht
ertrinken complete s badet wie sweet
stoffbahn das sind gamer das hündchen
gameplay
ich habe gebratenes hühnchen bekommt von
lpl den youtube user namens ophone lp
tlp bestimmt wenn das video online kommt
macht sich einen account nicht gibt ja
sonst wenden lp das sehen sollte sollte
bitte unterschreiben hallo ich bin hohen
lp und ich hab euch alle ganz doll lieb
ich habe ganz viele eier zweier wenn man
sich anguckt dann passiert wenn du am
sterben nein wir sind einfach nur
taktisch nicht leben
ich habe langsam keine lust mehr alter
ohne witz ich setze mich jetzt in game
mode und dann
egal jetzt schafft das auch so ok ich
hab's geschafft den auch im game okay da
ich bisher immer gekommen bin mache ich
noch den letzten ich hab's geschafft
sofort beim ersten mal im game modell a
game mode 0
was sind da drin feuer resistenz ja ich
komme ich durch die tür
scheiße martin kommt es an ich komme
nicht durch die tür
guck mal auf meinem bildschirm zwei
minuten einfach nur geradeaus schwimmen
noch gehen ich sprinte alter ist es
langweilig heike nach hinten
aber du musst auch auf eine ära guck mal
ich mach dich anzogen
ich frag mich etwas das hier bringt
einfach nur die dauer so herauszögern
also ich habe noch eine minute 30 feier
resistance müssten eigentlich schaffen
ach du bist so sexy
ich weiß du nicht du bist das segment
ich muss vor dem weg dahin eigentlich
durch auch martin theoretisch könnten
ausländer aufnehmen
nein danke war gleich nach hause
el hamma jetzt noch 11 ich muss morgen
für auch schöne frühes formation um 12
uhr
nein ich muss wirklich früher aufstehen
ptfe kommt nicht her
ja geil
wenn man teilweise in der lava drin ist
kann man kurz den boden sehen die bauern
hey ich habs wurde er einfach am rechten
bildschirm der rechten seite lang
ich hab noch 30 sekunden du bist im
creative hab ich gar nicht gemerkt
scheiße lappen deswegen war es auch so
schnell durch die lage ich bin aber die
ganze zeit nur leertaste gedrückt
gewesen
ich bin genauso schnell wie du schaust
du ja scheiße alter noch 15 sekunden ich
weiß nichts erschaffen
ich gebe den park knopf drücken und
schaffe ich es neun sekunden ich hab's
geschafft
außerdem bremst jetzt noch zu tode gehe
ich auf den schalter gedrückt
tt.com runtergefallen
ach du scheiße und ich bin wieder am
anfang alter wie behinderte ist das denn
ist auch gestorben
da warte ich darüber ziemlich gut zu dir
ja ich war immer gebaut und dann war
hier tnt und ich bin nicht gestorben wir
jetzt eigentlich moment hier sind wir
hier hergekommen
du bist aber noch ein game ordner martin
nein ich bin ich beim game hey ich habe
sie gefunden ja ich auch okay gut bild
ist der user buttons game schon gang und
ich war kein mord 0
wildes der
jetzt müssen wir die ganze nacht so wir
müssen es anders machen du welchen druck
was haben
ich weiß das ist reihe eins plus eins
ach so ja einst müssen noch zwei noch
einer bei 1 oder geht er nicht mehr weiß
ich
doch ja ok 1 ist fertig das heißt zwei
jetzt müssen noch ganz viele toll es war
noch einmal drücken giorgini egal ich
habe übrigens noch einen sandweg
darunter verlassen musste darf sich
zuschneiden ist was macht er die backe
kaputt warte so noch weiter dass ich
noch ein paar fünf ungefähr jetzt noch 4
ja mach einfach so genau das geht am
schnellsten klee bei drei noch noch ein
jetzt bereits fertig